i met shelly um fremont junior high when
we started seventh grade together
and when we we went to junior high
together and then we
graduated from las vegas high school
there was a lot of us that graduated
together and
unlike some people most of us have
have kept in touch we're one big family
the the class of 82 and even 81 and 83
we all keep in touch and um and
everybody's reaching out to me giving me
their condolences and everything but
the thing is that shelley wasn't just my
friend shelley was
everybody's friend shelley was had the
heart like
i mean she was just such a kind
compassionate
person and i mean anything i needed
she was there for me i mean i remember
when i was uh
pregnant i had just just had my son and
the doorbell were ringing there was
nobody there but there'd be a
a bag of diapers you know she always
took care of my mother too
she'd come to my mom and bring her her
chocolates and her lollipops
you know she would spend the holidays
with us she lost her mother
a few years ago and that tore her apart
and she has two brothers michael and
anthony
and her father toby and her and toby are
just so close so very close um
he's had some health issues but before
the pandemic they were um
every sunday they go to church and she
was getting very close to
to god into jesus christ and her father
i her father got her going there and
you know her and i would discuss a lot
about god and death and
stuff like that so i'm just so grateful
that she knew who jesus was and who he
is
and that's what this is all about it's
keeping our faith
we have to keep our faith and we have to
treat each other nicely what's happened
in this world lately i don't understand
but it wasn't like this a few years ago
i mean
when i was growing up i would never
think of anybody doing that to me
we could walk the streets here in las
vegas we could go anywhere
now you can't let your kid go in the
front yard
you know and my friend is gone she's
gone because
of some senseless act of violence
and it's it's just so sad what's
happened it's sad that's
what's happened to me what's happened to
my friends here
and um to all of us
to all of us you know i i don't get that
phone call anymore in the morning with
her
i don't get to experience that anymore
what's the legacy you think she leaves
behind here
it's to be kind to be kind
to treat yeah to treat each other the
way you want to be treated
shelley was just i'm not just saying
this i mean
she was just a very nice person just a
very
nice person you know
she was born and raised here in las
vegas yes she was
yeah she was born and raised here in las
vegas and
she loved vegas her father was in the
casino industry and
she she followed his footsteps like you
know lonnie said she became
she started front desk as a clerk and
she made it
she crawled she crawled up that ladder
and she just got promoted to director
of hotel of the hotel management
and she was so proud of herself and i
was so proud of her we were
all proud of her you know she was
learning new things and she was really
excited about this
new time in her life this new era and it
was just taken away it was just taken
away from her and from us
um would you consider her a
career-driven woman oh absolutely oh my
goodness
yes yeah she and she loved it she
enjoyed it
she enjoyed it she she loved the company
she worked for
she her the people she worked for she
was very
uh empathetic with them you know she was
very empathetic with all her workers
that's why she has so many friends
what were some of her interests here in
the valley
well she liked to bike rides like she
took this up recently
um but she also liked to you know she
she'd like to go to the gym
and and work out you know but her and i
you know we would go to concerts and uh
when we were younger oh my god we were
we were we'd love to go dancing
you know we just we just had fun roller
skating when we were younger
yeah we had a lot of good times and a
graduate of las vegas
yeah yeah we all graduated from las
vegas high school and like i said um
we're still in touch with with our
friends i mean there's like
maybe 70 of us that still keep in touch
and uh
everybody's devastated we just can't
believe this has happened
to shelley this shouldn't have happened
to anybody this shouldn't happen to
no one to no one i don't know what's
going on
but you know maybe we just need we need
a little more prayer and
faith in in our society
is there anything you would want to say
to the people who were involved that day
who there were people who turned around
the person who drove off was arrested
anything you would want to say
during this time i have nothing to say
about the person that was arrested i
believe in the justice system but
more i believe in god and for the people
that were there for my friend
i thank you so much that she wasn't
alone at that moment
because i couldn't be there for her and
i just thank everybody because there are
good people out there there's more good
people out there than bad people
and those good people were there for her
we just have to learn from this we have
to learn that there's a lesson here and
we
have to stop we all have to stop
is there anything else i'm just going to
miss her i'm going to miss her laugh
i'm going to miss our phone calls in the
morning
both of us before we went to work we'd
be called talking to each other
and i don't have that anymore i don't
have it
it's gone she's gone
we don't have her but would you say you
now have each other
to lean on oh of course i mean
we're going to lean on each other i mean
i love this man there's no way
he's going to be out of my life and and
her and
her husband her husband is one of the
wildcats from
from vegas i have a you know we have a
strong community
like i'm telling you it's a strong
family that we have from las vegas high
school
and we will all be there for each other
we will and
we we are going to become better people
not worse people from this
we are all going to become better
anything else no just i'm going to miss
her
i already missed her thank you
yeah thank you